Дві подруги, обидві самотні,
вирішили звернутися до інтернету в пошуках партнера.
Він запитав мене про подорожі.
Тоді ми почали переписуватися. Я не люблю писати,
тож ми доволі швидко зустрілися.
Потоваришували і зрозуміли, що в нас багато
спільних інтересів. Він хотів подорожувати, тож ми
почали одразу планувати спільну подорож.
Одна з переваг у тому, що ви уникаєте
незручних ситуацій. Якщо ви пасуєте одне одному і
хлопець зацікавлюється тобою, то уникаєш
складних моментів, коли наприклад, сумніваєшся,
чи варто мені підійти і заговорити з ним, чи він
справді на мене дивиться, чи є в нього дівчина.
Для тих, хто займається бізнесом знайомств,
зростання популярності таких онлайн-порталів
стало справжнім джек-потом. 2016 року дохід
у цій галузі тільки у ФРН склав понад 200 мільйонів євро.
А загалом у світі – більше чотирьох мільярдів.
Нашою службою користуються навіть люди,
які ведуть активне соціальне життя і насправді
не потребують цього. З іншого боку, технології стали
значно доступнішими. Навіть люди похилого віку
знайомляться в інтернеті, а значить, клієнтів стає
дедалі більше.
12 мільйонів німців шукають кохання в інтернеті.
І майже кожне третє подружжя у ФРН
познайомилася в онлайні. Проте у всіх –
різний досвід. Ця жінка витратила кількасот євро
на спеціальну послугу - онлайн-підбір партнера
протягом півроку. Проте після кількох тижнів
невдалих побачень відмовилася від цієї ідеї.
Все занадто швидко відбувалося.
Не встигаєш розібратися, хто ж перед тобою.
І це аж ніяк не романтично. Безперечно, комусь
може пощастити, але мені бракує романтики.
Та й постійно треба бути в мережі,
негайно відповідати, навіть якщо я на роботі
або з друзями. Тому мені це не підійшло,
але не страшно.
Чи шкодять бізнесу такі невдачі?
Звичайно, нам потрібні клієнти, які знаходять
своє кохання. Це на користь нашій репутації.
Проте варто бути реалістами: з віком потрібно
більше часу, щоб розпочати і розвивати стосунки.
Чи допоміг інтернет нашим героїням знайти долю?
Я спробувала різні варіанти. Одне чи два побачення
були реально нудними, але не більше одного-двох.
Решта завжди були цікавими і прикольними.
Деякі переросли в триваліші стосунки.
Але чоловіка мрії я поки не зустріла.
Коли ми планували свою подорож, то
дуже зблизилися. Потім подорожували разом
4 місяці й таким чином пізнали одне одного.
Ось уже три роки, як Юдіт у стосунках
зі своїм онлайн-хлопцем. Обидві подруги
аж ніяк не жалкують, що вирушили у онлайн-пошуки
кохання.